so it is decided,
who drives 2.024 for Germany to the ESC.
the heart of this is the german final.
there are 2 ways
how the participants were selected.
way 1,
most of the acts were directly selected by NDR.
the acts
could apply with their own song or
were published by NDR
directly addressed.
all songs were then rated by the ESC editorial team.
the top 32 were given a
Experts on the panel
presented and they evaluated it.
after a live audition
will then be the perfect mixture for the German
Finale compiled.
away number 2,
I want to go to the E.
S. 10.
together with Conchita,
Sausage and regave
we have From the applications also
15 promising Ex selected.
these go through 1 boat camp,
rather the best 4 in the live decision
one week before the
German final for the favor of the
audience and enter the German finals.
you can see more from 25.01 in the ARD Mediathek.
at the german final then give
as at est later also technical harnesses and audience
half of the points in each case.
who has the most points at the end,
Horse for us to ESC after my garbage
now comments under this post
who should enter the German ESC Final
and makes the plus go away,
so that you also always
the latest news about the best and
greatest music competition in the world gets.